three two one
go had unknowingly wanded right up to
the front line the first gunshot
signaled the beginning of another day's
Mayhem a roue uncforblyiliar with over
the next days gangs Kid r the city so
sold of the
[Musique]
variousb human
ieur bonjour Je vous intervie
aujourd'hui pour une chaîne Youtube qui
s'appellew j'aurais voulu avoir des
petites réponses sur votre dernier film
concernant les armes chimiques comment
s'appelle-t-il film s'appelle arm
chimique sous la mer et vous l'avez
réalisé il y a combien de temps on l'
réalisé l'année dernière il a été
diffusé sur la chaîne art en février en
février 2014 donc ce film traite de des
arsenaux mondiaux en fouie sous la mer
dans les lacs un peu partout en Europe
quel était l'endroit le plus pollué que
vous avez pu visiter en fait le c'est
surtout les les armes chiques qui ont
été J était dans les océans dans les
mers dans toutes les océans du monde et
on a filmé partout dans le monde TR
quatre continents et on peut dire que
l'océan ou les mer la plus polluée
c'était la Baltique sans doute pollu
avec quoi dans la Baltique c'était
surtout la gaz moutarde qu'on appelle le
en français le hit je crois hperit voilà
et quel est le risque en fait de cette
cet enfuissement sous la mer
euh quels sont les risques c'est surtout
les risques sont pour les pêcheurs pour
les pour les poissons et pour
l'environnement
euh de la mer tous les organismes qui
sont là les les chercheurs que vous avez
pu rencontrer qui enquêtaient sur ce
sujet-là euh vous ont donné un délai un
temps critique euh le problème c'est que
la plupart de ces armes ont été jettées
après la seconde guerre mondial il y a
des des armes qui ont été jeté avant ça
pour la première guerre mondiale mais la
plupart on été jeté après la Seconde
Guerre mondiale et ils ont été jetés
dans des euh français que c'est Barel
c'est barils des barils en métal
et ces barils ont une vie à cause de la
corrosion la corrosion de plus ou moins
50 ans c'est-à-dire que nous sommes
maintenant on arrive à la période
charnière voilà c'est c'est le moment
critique où ces armes
vont barelles sont en train de de
s'ouvrir et ses armes chimiques sont en
train de est-ce que vous avez enquêté un
petit peu sur la Manche sur la mer
Méditerranée la Côte d'Azur oui euh
surtout il y a même ici en France il y a
sur la Côte d'Azur il y a des zones même
aujourd'hui on voit des signes où on
peut pas se baigner mais on ne sait pas
pourquoi il mais c'est à cause de des
armeschées qui ont été jetés là et
surtout on a on a pas filmé en France
mais on a filmé beaucoup en Italie la
côte adriatique qui a vraiment une autre
côte qui est très très pollu après la
Baltique on peut dire que c'est l'Italie
même qui a beaucoup euh des AB qui se
trouve dans l'océan Adriatique vous avez
rencontré la population est-ce que vous
vous avez discuté de la avec la
population du risque qu'il
encourrait la plupart de la la
population ne sont pas au courant de ce
problème parce que c'est un sujet très
très secécré qui a été personne n parlé
de ça et vraiment on peut dire que ce
film c'est la première fois que
euh ça a été
discuté dans publiquement il y a eu des
enquêtes qui ont été fait par des
journalistes surtout en Italie un
journaliste qui acé un livre il y a
je sais pas combien d'années mais c'est
assez récemment il y a 5 ans mais c'est
c'est un nouveau sujet et quand à part
ça qu' on a parlé avec des personnes
qu'on était en train de filmer au bord
de la mer soit de la Baltique ou
soit en Italie et on rencontrait des
gens et on nous demandait qu'est-ce que
vous faites on leur demandait est-ce que
vous savez qu'il y a des armes chimiques
tout le monde était très choqué je pense
que la population ne sont pas au courant
et c'est un sujet qui effraye beaucoup
vous avez été choisi pour être le
réalisateur les réalisateur de ce
documentaire parce que vous étiez à la
base aussi réalisateur d'un film qui
s'appelle entraxoir est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire deux mots sur ce film
là oui le film
in c'est un film qui r à la situation de
des
sybiologique en ce moment les les
recherches qui se
passent développement des es biologiques
et vraiment c'est un film qui a démarré
après les attaques de d'rax ou juste
après le 11 septembre aux États-Unis des
lettres qui contenaient derax ont été
envoyé à des des médias et à des
quelques sénateurs américains à
Washington et et vous avez enquêé sur
les souches de cette anentrax oui on on
a enqué c'était une des une des choses
qu'on a fait dans ce film c'est de
regarder le sou de Crax pour
savoirù ça venait et de de faire une
investigation qui était forensique en
comment dit et donc qu'est-ce que vous
avez mis en avant sur C souche
là si on regarde cette souche c'est une
souche qui est ce qu'on
appellelais uneche
militarisé euh et qui était très très
sophistiqué qui a été travaillé
beaucoup de moyens et la conclusion en
fait euh que
c'était une souche qui était vraiment
travaillée que c'est ça devait venir
d'un d'un projet
d'État que c'était pas possible que une
personne
ou même un petit groupe de personnes
puissent développer une souche pareille
sont des grands grands moyens votre avis
est-ce que vous pensez que c'était une
façon dont l'État avait d'intimider
certaines institutions pour légitimer
quelques lois
antiterroristes face à la propagation
d'armes biologiques on ne peut pas
savoir les les raisons en fait mais on
peut pas spéculer vraiment mais mais
c'est sûr que
euh ce qui est arrivé que
ces attaques ont
lancé une beaucoup de nouveaux
recherches sur les es biologiques et
beaucoup de très très grandes dépenses
et des grands budgets qui ont été fait
sur ça mais on sait vraiment que aussi
que les armes biologiques on en parle
pas beaucoup mais que tous les États
sont en train de travailler sur
çaen vous êtes reporterur de guerre vous
avez fait quelques passages pendant
certains conflits comme morovia à la
belle époque euh qu'est-ce qui vous a
déterminé ou qu'est-ce qui vous a
prédestiné à enquêter sur ce type de
scandale d'arme
biologique pour moi ça venait de j'ai
grandi en Afrique euh zimbab au Zimbabwe
à l'époque c'était la colonie anglaise
la rodisie nous avons vécu une guerre
très violente d'indépendance et moi j'ai
grandi dans la société
de Colon j'étais un petit col comme un
petit colon et quand je j'ai attenu
l'âge l'âge majeur la guerre était en
pleine force là et beaucoup de mes amis
de l'école ont été faire la guerre et
moi je l'ai pas fait je me suis je me
suis enfu mais après que je suis devenu
journaliste j'ai su que les forces
risien les
armées l'armée du gouvernement
a utilisé les armes euh biologiques et
les armes euh chimiques euh et surtout
ils ont utilisé l'anthrax on peut dire
que le zimbabweé a eu la plus grande
épidémie d'anthrax dans l'année
euh
1998 euh qui a tué euh plus de 300
personnes et infecté plus de 10000
d'accord et c'était je me suis trouvé
après en en 2001 à New York juste à
l'époque de l'attaque d' Antrax et je me
suis demandé est-ce qu'il y a un lien
entre ce qui s'est passé dans mon pays
de zimbabweé et ce qui s'est passéit aux
États-Unis et c'est ça qui a démarré le
film c'estour de conséquen ce type de
raisonnement ouais c'était une question
c'était intéressé pour voir est-ce que
il y a un lien est-ce que dernière
question pour vous Bob
euh quel est le le le pire conflit que
vous avez été amené à voir durant votre
carrière de reporteur de
guerre tous les les conflits
sont sont mauvais sont terribles la
guerre c'est quelque chose de d'affreux
à
expériencer mais on peut dire
peut-être l'ivéia c'était
particulièrement on peut dire un peu fou
à cause que céit des jeunes hommes qui
étai des jeunes gens qui étaient drogués
avec des
Ares beaucoup de confusions beaucoup de
désordres et beaucoup de dangers
présentez-nous votre Amic alors je vous
présente mon mon associé Eric nadla on a
on a travaillé ensemble sur les deux
films les armes
chimiques sous la mer et notre film
atrax war qu'on a fait ensemble aussi et
ça fait 10 ans que nous travaons
enssazscentary 2
years what Drew me to this to is had
interest for many years in weapons of
mass destruction
whicht with the nuclear weapons
underground and we had exclusive access
to the first man accused of nuclear
espionage since Klaus fuk back in the
50s he was a German um he had access to
uranium enrichment technology um uh for
a firm where he worked and he took those
plans and he sold them to um Iraqi
agents for Saddam Hussein and there was
a worldwide Manhunt on for him after
those plans were found in a chicken
cooup uh that the United Nations
inspectors were sent to by uh uh
Hussein's uh brother-inlaw and uh as
soon as they saw the plans they knew
that this man carlheim SH had taken them
and he was hiding in Brazil and uhuse he
didn't think thered be an extradition
Treaty he also was helping Brazilians
with their secret nuclear program
helping them to Devel a nuclear
submarine among other things but
eventually the Brazilians extradited
into Germany he stood trial he was
accused of treason and nuclear espionage
he was found guilty and he was find
32,000 EUR and given a suspended
sentence he's a free man today and um
this was my first film on weapons of
mass destruction and then uh Bob and I
got together
bi we and weic we all ones and may
that's us now I don't know ok I would
point of view about the war in Iraq so
they talk about we of M
destruction arsenal of SAM was he and
legitimat the war this
pr point of
is at some in the 190s he had a nuclear
program as many countries do
it and there was no real information
that he
had revived it again um he certainly had
the software the plans to that he obtain
from SH for uranium technology very very
very sophisticated stuff once he had
that who knows what he could do with it
could sell it whatever but the pretext
that he had biological weapons that he
had nuclear weapons um was uh never
proven so the basic justification uh for
that War I think was an illegitimate one
ultimately i think they cooked the books
the Americans cooked the books skewed
the data linked it to the media created
a frenzy and uh to this day they haven't
found any proof that his program
continued in a sophisticated manner uh
despite some moves back in the 90s in
fact
maradfi had a sophisticated program as
well he gave up the program um and uh
was one of the few countries to actually
give up program I don't know if that was
wise or not cuuse they eventually uh
ousted him and killed him um and so I
don't know what sign that sends to the M
and Iran what you do with your weapons
but as far as the Iraq war goes i think
it was illegitimate and I think it was
done
some sort of revenge for 9 but nothing
to do with 9 so I think it's been a
tragedy for the region and the
world what was your your reaction when
you saw Colin po with a little bit of fr
who SH down tracks in front of a lot of
diplomatic persons well this is before I
done serious research into this topic
for the film this is when I was just an
American citizen and I was alarmed in
other words
if the American intelligence people had
convinced Colin Pow who was kind of a
career soldier not a real spooky Guy to
stand up in front of the world and say
that he was producing this well I was I
was concerned but as we know now the the
evidence was not there and the speech he
gave was false and so uh in retrospect
I'm angry about that and uh but at the
time I viewed it like most citizens and
was comme ça
Bob quand vous avez vu Colin Powell
agiter un peu d'antrax quelle était quel
a été votre réaction à l'époque et
quelle est maintenant votre réaction
c'était un point très très important
pour tout qui a été rentr en guerre oui
la rentrée en guerre c'était c'était
très important et dans notre film un
war c'est aussi un point très important
parce
que à travers de chercher l'histoire
qu'est-ce qui s'est passait dans les es
biologiques aussi on a inquiété sur les
morts de des chercheurs plusieurs
chercheurs et le plus fameux c'était
David Kelly qui était celui qui
avait dit parce que quand col Paul a
pris cette cet untrax c'était sur des
renseignement qu'ils ont eu à travers
les Anglais les Américains et en fait
euh
euh David Kelly avait parlé contre ça et
qui avait dit que que le dossier a été
sexta ça veut dire fabriqué
et et c'est à cause de ça que la BBC en
fait il a eu un grand scandale parce que
il avait dit
ça
unoficially mais la BBC à l'époque on a
donné son nom on l'a dit c'est lui qui
avait dit ça et ça a provoqué un très
très grand scandale euh en Angleterre
qui a
presque forcé Tron HBL à démissionner à
cause à cause de ça et qui en fait a a
causé la mort d'une façon et d'une autre
de de David Kelly on a dit qu'il s'est
suicidé euh quelques jours après que il
a été devant le Parlement anglais pour
répondre à des questions sur le sujet
et c'était un
suicide très suspect dans beaucoup de
choses et mais
alors sans doute euh c'était un moment
très très important pour euh pour les
grandes puissances pour rentrer en Irak
et et comme nous le savons maintenant 11
septembre l'Irak nous vivons les
conséquences jusqu'àaujourd'hui
je vais vous poser une dernière question
à vous deux puis une avantdernière
question pardon et puis une dernière
question nous avons la chance d'avoir de
américains en face de la caméra je
voudrais avoir votre perception sur le
concept de guerre contre le terrorisme
terror it's hard to understand what
groups are out there who's doing who's
behind it who benefits from the chaos
that this war on terror causes um I know
a few things that have been done in the
name of the war on terror that uh
frighten me as a citizen uh basically in
terms of the United States the passing
of the Patriot Act civil liberties are
threatened in fact in the recent
Revelations ofward Snowden we see that
national security state is an
international surveillance state gege
Orwell 1984 has come in the of the war
on terror
um it raises the question whether safety
or Liberty or
freedom can be Tred off in a way that
benefits many citizens so I think a lot
is done by the State in terms of the war
on terror that goes beyond things theyve
ever done before and you go to the roots
of who's actually the terrorist out
there a few i don't know
h people a handful of people are causing
these problems and uh the films we're
doing lately look into these shadowy
Wars we're really not sure who the
players are who they're working for so
it raises a lot of questions the war on
terror makes me uneasy a because if
there are two terror doing terrible
things that's horrible thing but if
someh governments are manipulating the
situation to increase their powers
that's also troueling so I'm really
troubled by the entire scenario of the
post 91 World uh i live in New York City
um i edited a film uh downtown Manhattan
every night I looked out and I saw the
sming R the world trade center and the
world that my childrenw up in
[Musique]
votre perception de la guerre contre le
terrorisme c'est on peut dire c'est une
guerre de l' il y a beaucoup de choses
qu' qu' ne sait pas
et on doit se demander qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire le terrorisme aussi j'ai
grandi aussi en Afrique et la guerre de
libération on nous a dit quand j'ai
grandi que c'était des terroristes aussi
et qui sont les vrais terroristes
qu'est-ce que c'est que le terrorisme en
fait mais aussi on doit regarder que
après la guerre froide euh que on avait
besoin on a toujours besoin d'un d'un
méchant d'un ennemi d'un ennemi de
quelqu'un d'avoir peur euh et pour
d'abord contrôler les gens mais surtout
aussi il y a l'aspect économique que des
des dépenses immenses
des budgets la
militarisation des
[Musique]
armées sous le nom de la guerre contre
le terrorisme alors il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de questions qu'on se pose
et et ça vraiment on peut dire que
depuis que la guerre contre le
terrorisme va commencer après le 11
septembre vraiment le monde a changé
complètement dernière question
[Musique]
question authority as always i tell my
don't believe what you read in the
papers don't believe what your
government says think for yourself um
and basically
um organize around issues that
areimportant to you I think the hold of
the powers that be at least in United
States i think basically the government
is run by a military industrial complex
that superseds Republicans or Democrats
that has come to believe that war um is
very profitable venture we're living in
a time of eternal war and basically I
think you have to uh make the government
accountable uh for all its claims so
basically question authority and do not
be afraid uh to engage in civil
disobedience when you don't believe uh
[Musique]
c'est vraiment la même chose je pense
que on doit toujours ne pas accepter ce
qu'on ce qu'on nous dit de de demander
des questions de ne pas faire confiance
à ce qu'on nous dit de ce qu'on lit ce
qu'on voit à la télévision mais je pense
que les jeunes ils savent ça déjà je
pense que la génération sont déjà
saperçoit de ça et de ne pas avoir peur
aussi de ne pas de s'éduquer d'essayer
de de chercher des réponses de demander
des questions et surtout de ne pas avoir
peur que on doit pas avoir pe on doit
avoir du
courage et c'est vraiment à eux à
changer nous sommes notre
génération on a causé beaucoup de
problèmes mais on va laisser beaucoup de
problèmes pour pour les jeunes et c'est
vraiment à eux c'est dans leur main de
de changer aussi de d'utiliser la tech
technologie qu'ils ont d'une façon
intelligente parce que la technologie
l'Internet et tout l'information qu'ils
ont au bout de doigt ça peut être
utilisé d'une façon négative pour le
contrôle qu' qu'on l'a vu mais aussi ça
peut
être utilisé d'une façon très très
puissante pour changer propager une épie
du bien grâce une épidémie du bien grâce
à technologie voà c'est ça exactement
merci beaucoup messieurs je vous
souhaite une très bonne journée un
[Musique]
PL à partir du moment où on autorise les
opérateurs à faire ce qu'ils veulent sur
le réseau en fait on les autorise à
modifier la société on les autorise à
modifier la façon dont les gens
interagissent de mieux en mieux o il y a
de plus en plus d'opportunités de plus
en plus de savoir et de talent et de
plus en plus de solutions et de plus en
plus de capitaux voilà pour des projets
c'estàdire que ce qui manque à l'heure
actuelle que dans beaucoup de pays on
fait évoluer le cadre institutionnel
pour inclure la société civile dans le
débat et on est très loin de faire ça en
France je pense c'est même un peu la
terreur des institutions